Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say'!
Do you know what to say when you meet someone face-to-face for the first time?
Listen out for useful language for meeting face-to-face.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Hi.
Hi, Eva.
How are you?
I'm very well.
I love your hair.
It's fabulous!
Thanks, Noelia!
Are you Noelia?
Vanya?
Yes!
Hello! It's so good to finally meet you in person!
You too!
It's great to put a face to a name.
I thought you were in Spain this week.
I was, but I came back early.
So, how are you finding it here?
Fine!
Really good!
All the team have been so welcoming.
Good!
We have a lovely team here.
Now, has Emir set you up with an email address?
He has.
I'm all ready to go!
Perfect!
Is there anything else you need?
Not right now, thanks.
Well, let me know if I can help at all.
I will, thank you.
Actually, I've got an idea.
What are you doing later?
I haven't got any plans.
Great.
Meet me here at six.
Don't be late!
So what's the plan?
We're going to see the local area by bike.
I'll show you all the best coffee shops.
Cool!
Let's go!
Hello again!
I think Noelia and Vanya are going to get on really well!
So, did you notice the useful phrases
used for meeting face-to-face?
Listen to me and then repeat.
It's so good to finally meet you in person.
It's great to put a face to a name.
How are you finding it?
Has Emir set you up with an email address?
Is there anything else you need?
Let me know if I can help at all.
What are you doing later?
I haven't got any plans.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time
you meet someone face-to-face in English.
Bye for now!